when a business stops making money is
tempting to stop investing in it and is
blatantly obvious that's exactly what
Israel's done the dining room is tatty
and the kitchen is lacking some of the
basic essentials you've got to give this
man the tools in order to operate this
[ __ ] restaurant properly I'm
frustrated that we've got a freezer full
of crap
and we got an oven that doesn't work so
we got to get our priorities right your
business you're employed as the head
chef you both have to start speaking the
same language
that's absolutely critical I hope this
is the beginning of things to change and
if you leave has felt in the past day
he's been put on the pressure to cut
corners and did not cut corners without
talking to me with the lines of
communication open and the promise of
vital equipment on the horizon Phillip
and I can start thinking about the food
do you think the menus too big yes
maybe finally we're starting to get
somewhere to put in lunchtime diners is
out with fusion confusion and in with a
snappy menu tasty fresh food that can be
pushed out quick you see what trying to
do I'm just trying to lift it I don't
want to get complicated these guys are
in a position to get anything
complicated done that for the obvious
damage and Phil's come up with a classic
French sandwich to get our creative
juices flowing so you're quite
passionate about a croque monsieur
I do like it yes when you're so
passionate about something as nice and
delicious as this how can you make that
baguette with the chicken and the
plastic cheese I know this is water for
ducks back for you you're a Frenchman
this surely must be the kind of food you
like cooking if it's because I've seen
you more relaxed to the last ten minutes
and I have in three days yeah yeah be
nice you two give a little bite to the
guys and tell me about it I show him a
little bit of sort of you know we have
passion at last some real food and it
smells delicious
you've away from Dijon huh you're happy
with that one aren't you
happy with it very nice yeah also know
what do you think I like hmm when you I
get chicken but yet a [ __ ] sure I
think a carbonyl is much better because
yeah it looks better tastes better
we're gonna take a picture why are we
taking a picture pillock that curd so
there it becomes idiot-proof no matter
how easy you think the sandwich is it's
still possible to damage a business on a
[ __ ] sandwich in the past year philip
has already changed the menu four times
to no effect so it's not surprising that
israel needs a little reassurance that
another new menu is the right step if we
agreed that we're gonna cook it this way
yeah and it changes in and cuts corners
that is frustrating when I talk about
reintroducing menus I'm not talking
about [ __ ] food that's over his head
I'm talking about soups sandwiches there
and straightforward dishes that you can
identify that are idiot proof and
[ __ ] delicious that's music to my
ears
that's all but it's not just the food
that's been letting the place down they
burn it in a word to me ever since I
arrived
he's talked the talk but done little to
back it up you have fallen for the
biggest problem any restaurant manager
has with their staff you become their
best mate and that's pissed off a few
people in here you can't afford to run
this restaurant as your social event
otherwise mate you are behaving much
longer turning me into my own show then
that's probably got the best of business
but the easiest you're running a [ __ ]
smart cool cafe bar new start Stan
apart from your staff